Facebook is introducing a new feature if  you heard of this where you can select  up to nine Facebook friends that you'd  like to date yeah yes this new feature  is called cheating thanks Facebook I  also like weird stories this is a really  weird one in Britain tests of English  River shrimp found that every single one  of them had traces of cocaine in their  system seriously yeah yeah that explains  that explains the number one complaint  about English river shrimp it tastes  like it's been awake for days that's the  big problem yeah yeah  this shrimp thinks it's funnier than  this shrimp is laughing really loudly in  its own jokes